(light music)
(audience clapping)
- [Ali] You have like a
whole living room in here.
- I know. I've got a whole living room.
Welcome to my house.
I am gonna get to "Beef"
'cause I'm obsessed with it.
- Please, get to the "Beef".
- I'm gonna get to "Beef",
but I'm gonna be a polite host
and ask 'cause I know you're
a mama, so how are your girls?
- They're really good.
- [Kelly] Good.
- They're really sweet.
How old are your kids?
- [Kelly] Six and eight.
I got a boy and a girl.
- Mine are five and seven.
- [Kelly] Yeah, similar.
- It's a sweet age.
- It is.
- I can still run errands with them
and make them believe it's an adventure.
- I can't, you're, yeah, no.
My kids, I can't do that.
- You can't fool them anymore?
- No, I just, I bribe them.
- [Ali] Uh-huh, uh-huh.
- Yeah.
I'm like, either some days I bribe them
and some days I'm just like,
"No, you just have to go
'cause we're a family
unit and you gotta go."
So yeah. But good for you and your kids.
That's so awesome for you.
So do your girls travel
with you whenever you tour?
'Cause I've done the kid
traveling on tour thing
and it's hard.
- It's so hard.
I do bring my mom.
- [Kelly] Okay, that's smart.
- Sort of. But then you do
have to pay the grandma tax.
- Okay, what's the grandma tax?
- Nothing is free.
The unsolicited advice.
- [Kelly] Oh yes, yes.
- The constant, you know,
criticism about, like
how you're parenting.
- Yeah, that's super fun.
- [Ali] That's super fun.
- Yeah.
- But it's free.
- [Kelly] Yeah, absolutely.
- It's worth it.
- Yeah, I would pay someone. (laughs)
- Yeah, I know.
I might do that now too.
But my mom's like in the shallows
of senior citizenship now.
She's 83 years old.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So I'm like, this might
be her last go with us.
- And like, it's also so
fun for her with grandkids.
That's gotta be so cool.
- It's so fun.
And it's really fun for the kids too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So it's really interesting
for me talking to you
because there's not a lot
of other standup comics
who travel with their kids
'cause male standup comics,
they just never travel with their kids.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- 'Cause they have a wife.
- No, I know a lot of male
musicians don't either.
- [Ali] And we don't have wives.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Ali] Yeah, so like.
- I have a, I call her my
sister wife, my nanny. (laughs)
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- That's really nice.
- I wouldn't be able to,
'cause when you're on stage,
there's no one to watch your children.
So you have to have
someone watch them, so.
- Yes, so it's like,
I'm really curious about
like do you have any tips to share
about going on the road with kids?
- I honestly-
- [Ali] Bribes again.
- No, I honestly, I had to
let go a lot of the guilt.
Like, so whenever I went
on tour with the kids,
well, first of all, I used
to travel with dogs too.
- Oh my God.
- Before kids. Before kids.
And then I was like, "Well,
I'm not gonna leave my dogs
at home, that's rude. They're
used to going with me, right?"
And then I was like, "This
is a horrible decision."
- Yeah.
- So the dogs went home.
- How long do you last for with the dogs?
- Without the dogs?
- With the dogs.
How long did you bring the dogs on?
- Maybe, maybe two weeks I lasted
with children, dogs, and
work, like I was like,
"This is insane."
- Mother of dragons.
- Yeah, yeah. You feel-
- Many dependents.
- That dies at the end.
I was that version.
I was the one that was dying at the end.
No, it's very hard.
But I found that I had
to let go of the guilt
and I had help on the road.
And I had to say like,
"Guys, I can hang with y'all all night,
like after mommy's done",
but I don't go on stage,
you don't go on stage till late at night.
- Right.
- So it's like I had
to sleep in or my voice
would be like wrecked.
- I know.
- And all those people pay,
you know, their hard-earned money
to like not watch you suck.
- Totally.
- So, yeah. So, yeah.
- Yeah.
- So I had to tell them like,
"This is the schedule for tour."
Like during life, I
mean, I dropped them off
at school this morning and I come to work.
It's a normal thing, but
when you're on the road,
you're on the stage so late,
that it's like you have to
change your hours, I feel like.
- Yes, it's true.
- Yeah.
- And then it's like, "I'm
not reading to you anymore."
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- "That time is done.
We're putting that on pause."
- And when they give me crap, I'm like,
"Remember that video I sent you
with Ariana Grande talking to you?
Yeah, I don't wanna hear it."
I'm like, "No kid gets that."
(Ali laughing)
Remember that time?
I'm like, "You get some
cool perks, you know?
It's all right."
It is hard though. It's very hard.
And I do see why most men
leave children at home
'cause it's like, it's
not easy for them either.
- Period. No, I'm just
kidding. I'm just kidding.
- It's not easy for you to
do that work on the road
and also, like be a great present parent.
That's really hard, I think.
- Yeah.
I'm gonna do it, I think this
might be the last time I do it
because I hear that, you know, with kids-
- Well, then they start
school. It's harder.
- Their lives get really important and big
and if they miss out on a birthday party
or something, they're like (groans).
- [Kelly] Girl, you will hear about it.
- Right. Now it's,
we're not at that point.
So, this tour that I'm
going on this summer
will probably be like the last one
that I can take them and my mom on.
- It's fun that it's summer
too. That's a perfect time.
- [Ali] Yeah.
- For them to, yeah,
to go travel too.
That's a different kind of education
I feel like my kids have gotten,
and your kids probably too.
They get to travel around
to different cities and-
- It's true.
- Meet different people.
Like that's not a normal education
for, well, how I grew up, so.
- Yeah.
And it's so nice too
because like, you know how
in the city you live in,
you're like "I'm sick
of this science center.
I know where every single thing is."
- I'm not going to the museum again."
- "I'm not going to that museum again."
So it's so nice to go to
like a different park.
- [Kelly] Yeah, a different aquarium.
- Yes, a different aquarium.
See like a different
albino alligator, you know?
- This one's so different
from the last one we saw.
- Yeah, this one looks more like chicken
than the other albino alligator.
- Okay, do you have the,
do you feel like you have ability on stage
to talk about absolutely anything?
Do you feel like that kind of vulnerable?
I feel like you're that
person that is pretty open.
- I'm pretty open.
I can't, I'm like weirdly private too.
Like I'm sure in writing your songs,
there's like, it seems like there's things
that you choose to be really open about
and there's a lot of
songs where I'm guessing
is like an abstraction of the truth.
- Yeah.
- You know, and that's
in the same way that like
a self-portrait is like,
"Is your skin really that color?"
"Do your eyes really look like that?"
And it's like, "No, this
is my like perception
of how I'm seeing myself right now."
And that's what you're
presenting to people.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But that's also not forever.
You know, that's not how
you see yourself forever.
So that's the same thing
about like a song, right?
- Yeah, it's like different chapters too.
- Different chapters.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So that's sort of how I see it.
And I can't, I've tried to make
like political jokes before
and I just can't do it.
I would love to be that
person, but I can't do it.
- Are you too, like wholehearted
like opinionated about it?
Is that why? 'Cause I feel
like that's why I don't either.
- I think I just start to get angry.
- Me too. Like an inner rage
that I'm like, "Wow,
I'm such a bubbly person
but I'm getting very angry right now."
So you're going back on the road soon.
So when you're coming
up with new material,
do you like rehearse it?
Do you like stand up in
like your room and do that?
- Yes. No, I don't. I write on stage.
And I test out my material
at clubs and open mics.
- So like fresh? Just yes.
- Like fresh, so it's very,
and so what I do a lot of the time
is when I, it's really
all about the writing.
Like people think it's so
much about the performance,
but I mean, similar to music,
it's so much about word choice.
So I'll go up on stage and
in front of an audience.
Like they will never know that I'm coming
'cause I'll just drop in at a club
and they'll be like so excited
and then I can see their faces fall
'cause I'm trying out new stuff.
And I'll bomb and they'll literally,
I can see on their face,
like their inner thoughts
being like "She's lost it.
She's not funny anymore."
But it's like, "No, I'm
really trying to see
if the writing is good."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I'm trying to take
the performance out of it.
- That's so brave.
- So it'd be like
if you were like on-
- Testing out a song.
- If you were testing out a song,
instead of singing, you
just spoke the lyrics.
(both laughing)
In a monotone tone.
- You get to guess how the melody is.
- Since you've been gone. Yeah.
- This is so cool. I love Michelle Obama.
And she recently posted about you,
saying that you are one
of her favorite comedians.
So how did that feel? That's pretty rad.
Just to have fans, in general,
but somebody like her
to notice, that's cool.
- It felt amazing.
She had actually reached
out to me a couple years ago
and sent me a letter,
like a handwritten letter
and it's framed in my house,
where she wrote me about
how touched she was
that I talk about women's bodies
and what happens to our bodies
and make us laugh at the same time.
And she was like, "I think
that's really important."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so, yeah, of course.
I mean, it's her.
- That's cool. Yeah.
- So it means the world to me.
- Yeah.
- And I have not
yet to meet her.
She was, before COVID, she was set to come
to one of my shows in DC
and I think she bought like 25 seats.
I'm sure half of them were for
Secret Service but whatever.
They paid for the tickets,
so I appreciate it.
- [Kelly] Regardless.
- Yeah, and so I'm really, I
hope she comes this summer-
- Oh my gosh.
- To my show in DC.
- You're so funny, I cannot.
And especially if she's
watching this new show of yours,
we're gonna get to "Beef"
because "Beef" is so relatable
and I know you're probably like,
"Wait, it's relatable.
What's wrong with you?"
(Ali laughing)
And that's what you're thinking now too
if you've watched it.
But let's talk about it 'cause
it's your new Netflix series.
It's called "Beef".
Tell everybody what it's about,
like kind of in a synopsis.
- Okay, so "Beef" is
about these two strangers.
It's me and Steven Yeun.
- [Kelly] It's so good.
- So good. And we get
into a road rage incident
and then we become
obsessed with each other.
And our lives start to unravel.
And gosh, I can't say enough
about what a great guy he is.
I think most people probably know him
from "The Walking Dead." He's Glenn.
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, and it's cool because in this show
he gets to show a lot of
his like comedic chops.
He's such a funny person and-
- Hilarious, but I think
what's great about both of you
is you encompass like
every emotional state.
Like there's sadness, there's anger.
- Yeah.
- And like even having some,
even having that person to
just take it out all on.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
It's obviously not that person,
it's everything else going on around it.
But I think a lot of
people relate to that.
Do you relate to the character at all?
- I do relate to the character.
And I think just like her having this,
not feeling she has a space
to be angry or to be ugly,
I think a lot of women can relate to that.
- When he came at you about
that gratitude journal,
(Ali laughing)
it's like pick your moment, friend.
Like it's like, her
gratitude journal is great,
that's great, but like
when someone doesn't wanna hear about it
is when they're drowning.
- Yes.
I have like my husband in the
show is a super positive guy.
- So positive you kinda wanna punch him.
- And my character tries
to like really vent to him.
And he kind of shuts it down.
- [Kelly] He shuts her down.
- Yeah, in this very like positive way.
But it's still a shut down.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know? And so, yeah, so I get it.
- I think everyone's had that
where you're like "Oh no, no, no, no.
I really, it took forever
for me to even voice this."
- Exactly.
- "And now I'm voicing it
and you just shut it down."
- [Ali] Right.
- That's super fun.
- Yeah.
And it's also like that unleashing
and like venting is
also a form of intimacy.
And so when he shuts her down, it's like,
"Oh, you don't wanna go there with me."
You know, like this is
a very for us, because
it's essentially she was opening up.
- And yet guising it as like,
"Oh, I love you. I want the best for you."
And it's like, "Well, then
be a part of this with me."
It's really interesting,
the relationships in it.
The just anger in it, of like,
of just how life happens
and it's not perfect
and carrying the weight of everything.
Oh my God, that one point,
and your mother-in-law.
Oh my gosh.
- Oh yeah. (laughs)
- She does such a great
job of being unlikable.
Like I love it.
- Yeah.
- It's such a great show.
If you haven't seen it, guys. Oh my God.
What's up y'all? We are back
with Ali Wong. Give it up.
(audience cheering)
We do a segment here
where we dive into the things
we love called "Obsessions".
But while we're obsessed with many things,
there are also things
that we are just not into.
So today, in honor of
Ali's new show "Beef",
which is incredible and
you can see now on Netflix,
we are bringing you "Kelly
and Ali Can't Stand It".
♪ Kelly and Ali can't stand it ♪
Here's how it works, everybody.
We're gonna hit the button
and our super creepy super computer
will search through the
things that bother us most.
'Cause it totally knows that.
Then Ali or I will get to rant
about why we can't stand whatever topic
appears on the screen.
I will start. Here we go.
Boom.
(button clicking)
(bell dings)
Okay, I don't like sound in general.
Let's talk about sound in
general in movies and shows.
For some reason, recently it's gotten like
there will be like a horrible,
you know, an action movie
and it'll be like so loud
and then you can't hear the dialogue.
So you're constantly chasing the volume.
That drives me nuts.
But the worst is kissing sounds in movies.
I don't wanna hear (makes mouth noises).
I don't wanna hear that.
It doesn't sound like kissing
and it sounds like something
I don't wanna watch
in a room full of people.
Like it's just like,
it's just like not great.
I don't like kissing sounds.
I don't like over, it's like-
- It sounds too wet.
- The audio, it's a little too wet.
- It's a little too like mac and cheese-
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Being made.
- Yes, and it's just,
and you want to be like,
"Oh, what a nice moment.
Oh, they finally kissed."
And instead I'm grossed out.
- Yeah, you just hear like
saliva in a roof of a mouth.
- And you're like, it's like,
"Oh my God, it's about to happen."
And then (makes mouth sounds).
And I'm like, "What in
the? Who kisses like?"
This does not make anyone
wanna go out and find someone.
It makes you happy that you're alone
and that's not happening.
- I don't know, I kinda like it.
- Really?
- Yeah, I think it adds,
it makes it more like 3D to me.
- I don't mind a little bit.
- Yeah.
- A little bit
can go a long way.
- They oversell it.
Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it's a little much.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, here's you.
(button clicking)
(bell dings)
- Oh my God.
(Kelly laughing)
It's the worst.
- You are 100% talking about me.
- Oh man. We're never
gonna go to Dim Sum then.
- Do they Americanize it? Like is that?
- No, it's just like when I go, like for,
like when I was living in New York
and a bunch of standup
comics would be like,
"Take me to Dim Sum, I
wanna go to Dim Sum."
And then we'd go to Dim Sum,
and they'd be like, "What is that?
Ew, what is that? What
is that? What is that?"
- Oh, I don't do that.
- "What is that?"
And they're basically asking,
"Why is that not a sandwich?"
And it's like, "You asked
me to take you here."
- Oh, I don't do that.
- And also.
Also with like, with Dim Sum,
it's all pork and shrimp.
Just eat it.
- Yeah.
- It's all some version of pork.
- I love pork.
- Love pork.
- Love.
- [Ali] Love shrimp.
- Yeah, don't love shrimp.
I'm allergic, but like I love pork.
- Yeah, that good.
- Yeah.
I'm not that person. I will
generally try anything.
- As long as you're like, try it.
But it's mostly just all the questions.
- I just thought you were gonna say like,
you know how people are like,
"Oh, I love like Chinese"
and then they get like the
most Americanized basic,
they're like, "I love Indian food"
and it's like chicken tikka masala.
- [Ali] Right, right.
- It's like the one dish.
- Yeah.
- It's like that's the thing
that I thought you were gonna say.
- Yes.
- Yes,
'cause that's annoying to me
and I am one of those
annoying people, yeah.
- It's more when people are squeamish-
- [Kelly] I'm not squeamish.
- And ask a ton of questions.
- I don't like when
people food shame either.
When they poo on your food.
- Yucking your yum. Yeah.
- Yucking your yum.
Why did you just yuck my
food? Now I gotta eat it.
- [Ali] Yeah.
- And you just, you know,
verbally barfed on it.
- [Ali] It's so rude.
- Yeah, anyway. Okay, and there you go.
That was so helpful,
America, you're welcome.
That was "Kelly and Ali
Can't Stand It". Totally.